hey guys tim ferriss here author for our
body i wanted to show you some new
tricks that picked up in the last few
years this one was related to hamstring
flexibility I have notoriously terrible
hamstring mobility just oh can you touch
the ground my legs bent type of issues
and the first time I was ever in a yoga
class and other guys considered me the
flexible dude was after doing zero yoga
it was after doing a combination of
exercises probably six to eight but I'll
show you two of them that had a
particularly large impact and I want to
give credit where credit is due these
are directly from jersey Gregorek you
have to look this guy up he's incredible
check out some of those videos on
YouTube he's a four-time or five-time
Olympic weightlifting world champion he
is in his 60s and it's still more mobile
and stronger than I am and can do
everything cold he's incredible the
program that he created is called the
happy body so you can look up Gregorek
jersey Gregorek greg o r EK Gregorek and
definitely take a look but these are two
that I found very helpful and you should
look at the entire program because it
does piece together very well so the
first is is as follows you're going to
be on your back and this is a hamstring
stretch but it's also an abdominal
exercise of sorts and of course I'm
probably not doing this perfectly but
I'll show you what has helped me in any
case so I'm going to come here and arms
are overhead I'm going to take an inhale
I'm going to finish my terminal knee
extension pull my toes back and I'll
demonstrate first so watch
okay so I'm only going to do six or so
reps of that now a few key components
here you want your legs totally straight
as straight as possible so you're going
to have to contract your vastus medialis
and your quads to really lock it
toes back and when you come up I did add
one little thing to this which is
probably some type of sacrilege but I
will go as far as I can cut and then
I'll bring my hips back almost like
what's called the pike pulse in
gymnastics so the six reps that's it and
in that max range I'm only staying there
for a half second to a second it's very
very short okay that's exercise one
literally I might do one set of those in
the morning okay and then I would do
other exercises for low back squat etc
which Jerzy prescribes so you should
take a look at the full program but the
other hamstring specific exercise and
you as many that I found very helpful is
using dumbbells and there are a number
of different variations of this but
you'll notice I have a wide stance my
toes are pointing out and I'll show you
what you want to try to do and I may not
execute this perfectly but you do not
want to round at the back or
particularly the low back this is a
hamstring stretch so we want to kind of
lead with your gut if that makes sense
lead with your lower abdomen so going to
be here same breathing sequence I'm
taking a big breath in stretch complete
the exercise exhale this is what it
looks like and I'm pulling my toes back
okay so straight legs again
that's one rep that's it so you're not
spending a lot of time again at that max
end of your range it's very very brief
and I will typically just go down for
again half a second maybe quarter second
at most a second so it looks like this
toes back legs completely contracted not
this up and then shrug down exhale
that's the second you do five or six of
that that's it okay now Jersey would
most likely have you go through multiple
rounds of this and I would agree that
that is ideal but in a very rough
situation in the morning at five minutes
you can get a lot out of those two
exercises but please give credit to
Jersey and check out his program so
Jersey Gregorek again je r zy Olympic
lifting if you just search that you'll
find tons and tons on them do me a favor
and get his book or the DVDs he's
incredible one of the most amazing
teachers I've ever met so there you have
it hope this helped if you enjoyed that
video let's talk about a list our old
Swartz hanger Jamie Foxx undisputed king
of big wave surfing Laird Hamilton the
list goes on and on what do they have in
common they're sharing their secrets
their morning routines favorite books
everything with me on my podcast the Tim
Ferriss show 70 million plus downloads
iTunes best of 2015
check it out you will not be
disappointed